Brittany wrote in hey David besides
voting what do you think are the most
effective forms of activism donations
protests phone banking volunteering
writing public comments what are the
least effective I personally spend a
fair amount of time contributing public
comments on the federal register but
given that the administration is so
hostile to liberal views I've wondered
if it even matters because they will
just be ignored as the FCC did with net
neutrality so when it comes to activism
there's tactics versus strategy okay
whatever the tactics the most effective
activism is going to engage people
across political lines if that's
possible you will have a huge advantage
in successful activism if you can get
people involved in your movement
supporting your movement across
ideological and political lines so that
the movement cannot be written off as
merely partisan politics now
unfortunately people who watch the show
probably know that a lot of the really
important issues that we're facing today
are extremely partisan in nature so that
that is going to be very very difficult
to do so in terms of tactics not all
tactics are created equal so mass
demonstrations for example mass
demonstrations of support by flooding
the offices of lawmakers physically by
showing up in protesting and with
letters and emails and faxes and all of
that stuff that is a more effective
tactic than signing petitions on the
Internet
yeah period example a would be Jeff
Flake maybe was he may be changed his
mind on the Brett Cavanaugh situation
because of two female protesters young
accosted him hit an elevator
ultimately Jeff Flake didn't you know
stick to his guns and he ended up
supporting Cavanaugh in the end but it
held the investigation off for like
another week another example showing up
somewhere as part of a public
demonstration is probably more effective
than Facebook meme activism but I'm
coming up with sort of like extreme
examples right but I think the point is
that in terms of strategy you want a
message with that is inclusive and has a
broad appeal and in terms of tactics you
really want to think about which tactics
to apply the question that I think is
the most important one to ask when you
are considering strategy and tactics for
activism
is how do we influence public opinion
most effectively which tactics have the
potential to reach the most people and
swing public opinion because ultimately
the way our system works right now is a
system of constant running for
re-election every two years for the
House of Representatives every six years
for senators every four years for
presidents so if you can impact public
opinion such that it puts pressure on
lawmakers because they of course have to
think about their next re-election
campaign that is going to be a way to at
least have a chance of getting results
more quickly than if you aren't
influencing public opinion and only
lobbying lawmakers directly in the end
money right I mean unfortunately right
now we know that money wins more often
than not when it comes to the candidate
money wins very often when it comes to
which side of a political activism issue
has more money behind it so I I don't
like this we need to change campaign
finance but part of the strategy right
now has to be if you want successful
activism it has to consider that you
need money
yeah candidates do need money to get
their message out that's for sure it's
really just this about where the source
of that money comes from right I agree
instead of corporate PACs that'd be
great if we could get individual
contributions up similar to what Bernie
Sanders did in 2016 you know just just
twenty seven dollars at a time that's
all you need it would be great to remove
that altogether but as I've said before
for as long as that is part of the
political system to ignore it would be
absolutely silly and activism needs that
as well I don't like it I'm not saying
I'm not cheering the system we have but
what I'm telling you is that that's the
reality that we're dealing with I want
to hear from you about this what are in
your mind the most effective activism
tactics and what are the less effective
activism tactics let me know we've got a
great bonus show coming up for you today
sign up for membership at WWJ and
pokémon comm to get instant access it's
not just membership that gets you access
to the bonus show become a patron for at
least five bucks a month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show that'll also get
you access both work I will talk to you
on the bonus show